when I chose to leave Physical Therapy
uh to Embark in a career in standup
comedy I mean you know I I had a doctor
degree like it was a whole thing my
mother was like beside herself because
you know even when I went in I was
working with I was a pediatric physical
therapist I was working with mostly
mentally and physically handicapped kids
and uh I went in I was out of school and
I told the principal you know I'm going
to leave this career to do comedy um she
was like that you're never going to make
it she was like that is very very stupid
to do that she was like you you have
full health benefits here you're making
$47,000 a year so by the time I got to
uh in a place to quit I had already done
the David Letterman show I had already
that had already happened and um and you
know I had left physical therap I I I
was leaving my job uh in the New York
City Board of Ed I would sometimes not
show up and I would go on the radio or I
would go do a comedy gig and that for
the New York City Board of Ed called
theft of service they actually have
retired NYPD detectives that if they
find out that you're calling out sick
and you're not actually sick they can
like prosecute you so so I get a knock I
had quit already right I had quit I
didn't realize I was getting
investigated by the NYPD for theft of
service I had no idea this just
happening I had told my principal I quit
so then I'm just sitting there with no
money in my bank account being like did
I mess up here and then three days later
I get a knock at the apartment I was
living in and it's two detectives and
like like real detectives and they're
like are you Chris to Stephano I said
well you pronounced my last name right
and they I said thanks and and and and I
said and and they said uh and they said
we need to come in and they said where
were you on these these dates and I just
flat out told him I said listen I've
I've been on the radio okay I'm doing
comedy now I I said I quit I quit
physical therapy last week they said you
quit they said all right so then if you
quit don't worry about it cuz you were
going to get fired you were going to get
sued but they said if you quit no harm
no foul and then they had seen these
postcards uh the postcards from David
Letterman that you know I still had I
haven't even framed them yet and they
were like what's that I said oh I just
did the David Letterman show they go get
the out of here I said yeah they go
let's watch it so they sat down these
two detectives and just watched me do
this five minutes and the only the
detectives only comment was he goes you
know your suit was too big you look like
you swimming in your suit next
time get your suit tailored and I was
like oh my
thanks